una firma que da inicio a una nueva era
para las mujeres argentinas con el lema
es ley
el presidente alberto fernández llevó a
cabo el último trámite para la entrada
en vigor de la legislación de la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
después de que a finales del pasado año
el congreso y el senado hubiesen
aprobado la norma se trata de uno de los
grandes hitos de la legislatura
hoy es un día de felicidad para todos
porque lo que estamos haciendo es una
sociedad un poco más igualitaria un poco
más justa algunos estados conservadores
han pedido la inconstitucionalidad por
lo que la corte suprema tendrá que
revalidar la norma pese a todo argentina
se une otros países como cuba guyana
uruguay y algunos estados mexicanos con
la ley se pone fin a años de protestas y
reivindicaciones de la ya histórica
marea verde las mujeres podrán abortar
en las primeras 14 semanas de embarazo
garantizando una interrupción legal y
segura esta ley viene a dar respuesta a
un gravísimo problema de salud pública
que tenemos en la argentina hasta ahora
que es el aborto clandestino así han
dejado su vida
más de 3000 mujeres dice que recupera
con la democracia después de argentina
podría llegar el turno del vecino chile
que el miércoles inició la discusión de
un proyecto para despenalizar el aborto
en las primeras 14 semanas
el gobierno se opone pero el ejemplo de
argentina y la nueva constitución en el
horizonte pueden convertir a chile en el
siguiente país de américa latina en
lograr que la interrupción voluntaria
del embarazo sea legal